welcome to this video playing true true
from israel and is the first game of a
new session my rating has reached an
all-time low really the last two
sessions were totally yeah absolutely
terrible cannot really call it call it
something else and i hope to improve him
let's see yeah it's not like i was
playing so badly on the on for like one
or two weeks i was just playing two
longer sessions and in a row where I
probably should have stopped at some
point noticing that I'm not really in
great shape but I still continued it
always feels like okay found it that
type of writing how can you lose any
more points but I managed so I'm on to
2115 here let's see ok we have a Ben Oni
here modern been only the classical
variation with with an early form I'm
done let's see how how I should should
play here in many many ways I can still
play for them for the Queen side with c4
and possibly be five there are also ways
to play on the king site actually okay
looks like he is maybe preparing be sure
by their form okay should I play c4 c4
him will answer with a five very very
likely 95 he will drop the bishop back
and then play a form
okay I can also play for set up with g5g
five nine two g6 controlling the dark
squares it's a very aggressive way to
play
maybe it's possible could also try to
increase some pressure on the EVO b5 is
not a move that I'm so keen on playing
if it takes the a6 pawn is also very
weak and I'm content that he has played
has played the a 5 a-5 movie I you
always have to use a piece to protect it
as white like the rook on a one okay I
could go I can play 95m takes look
checks and foreign yup it's not it's not
so very dangerous so why not gain this
tempo on the bishop on c4 and now let's
let's go for the setup g5 and 90 m this
is now very securely controlling an e5
and therefore the only real drawback is
the weakness of them f5 square that's
something that I really need to need to
be a careful about that night coming to
f5 with some very very serious issue
okay he's preparing to play before it
seems yeah I wanted to go be should be
five and i will i will do that
exchanging the dark squared Bishop ism
is generally nice him yeah okay he goes
here but i will try to to do something
on the dark squares now let's see
I send a way to exploit those terribly
weak dark / I can eyeball stay only I
only have a check here really it's clear
that i will lose upon him okay maybe
give it up like that now go for the dark
squares
now I have underestimated underestimated
before rly that it is setting so quickly
now night will come to d3 maybe okay I
need to I need to be big cookie of no
use in doing anything check anything
fancy okay rookie form before 94 I guess
I guess so rookie for King tag I take
you one okay rook takes Knight X I have
95 coming a queen e five I mean sorry
Queenie five check ok the sea can cover
I can go here though Queen g3 now and
looking at the rook here yeah i'm not
sure what what this is objectively
speaking but it is certainly am an
interesting practical try 92 maybe not
clear what the benefit is i can do this
and the check on f3 though it's not
leading to much
time warning now this could be
interesting takes Queen f2 is just what
I want and I'm probably on chat knowing
that
hmm surprising that you played this and
so quickly yeah no I'm threatening some
discoveries IAM night f 2 93 and the
Queen here so it's insecure yeah the
check will win when they exchange but
will it win the game probably not him
alright it's very good down 90 to double
check what is he doing against that
taking the Queen and the bishop are
plundering the color I don't believe it
no what am I doing here ah I know oh I
don't know what it is I hate it how can
you be so all of shape the guy is
totally lost it I guess black resigns
it's really amazing I is not lost on it
give the computer says it's equal but I
came anyway am i not winning here i care
i can play king g one that's not so bad
because the Queen hangs ok check ok I
don't know what it is I'm totally I'm
totally I'm totally I'm not seeing and
don't see anything night 92 just dupes
ok so 93 check you can play King g1 yeah
yeah okay it's not sacrificed to its not
forced to to sacrifice the exchange
which I thought he was for some reason
and this is indeed winning for black
with the exchange of
okay can go here and here it's nothing
great i mean i can what i can do is i
can go into the end game and it's a pawn
down but it should be a draw yeah this
is a pretty easy drawn we will we will
exchange the whole whole pawns on the
queenside and then i have those two
against three and this is a very easy
draw you just put the king on g7 and
shuffle forever then double ponyo is
basically not not a poem i really don't
know what I'm doing here we had yeah
this this whole thing was interesting it
wasn't leading to an interesting play TM
yeah instead of night f4 which was okay
the funny thing was that he took it
basically immediately here pause to
think like he didn't see Queen f2 was
always a bit irritating but okay ya hear
I mean okay this is normal I also could
have gone here and this was also
interesting intending 9h form it also
seems to be quite good maybe this was a
bit bit bit trickier if he goes here I
have 9h phone and I'm winning yeah this
is this is absolutely deadly
check like this I must play King h1 it
seems and after that we can go here and
we have the same position as in the game
it can it can be to the exactly the same
position yeah maybe it's dynamically
equal and but it's not if you give away
your queen in one move okay thanks for
watching